ah bon j'accueille samy naceri et farid
khider
ah bah oui tu as bien bien merci
vous arrêtez toujours yves monette a dit
moi qui tu téléphones est là j'appelais
aller oui le l'organisateur le fondateur
de l'association idéaux
il arrive là ils en train il au
maquillage vous êtes ici tous les deux
et j'espère bientôt tous les trois pour
une soirée de boxe thaï qui s'appelle la
nuit des super fight le 22 octobre au
dôme de villebon box et taille c'est à
dire qu'à la fin on fait des massages
alors tarif vous vous êtes le boxeur ali
qui va nous rejoindre
lui c'est l'organisateur et vous ça me
vous êtes le mec qui utilisent la boxe
thaï contre les policiers
encore hier commence si à chaque fois
que j'en parle de la police ils me
parlent de la justice sinon on est là ce
soir pour parler de la boxe a mis ses
pas pour être désagréable mais c'est
vrai que chaque fois que j'entends
parler de toi tu es toujours dans une
embrouille dans le journal tiens j'ai un
dossier sur toi avant ouais pareil tu te
taper avec la police mais pas longtemps
la culture j'ai pas le permis non mais
c'est vrai c'est pas c'est pas grave
mais c'est vrai que chaque fois que je
vois dans le journal tu étais dans une
embrouille que les coffres
ben écoute il y en a d'autres
il arrive à mieux s'en sortir que moi je
fais pas comment ils se démerdent
commande chez pas comment ils font ils
ont des touches ils sortent ils rient
font deux heures au poste et ils sortent
moi j'y arrive pas il garde 24 heures à
chaque fois à chaque fois tête ont
permis en ce moment non j'ai pas de
permis étaient garés au c'est bien
gentiment la production de monsieur
ardisson envoyé une voiture a raison
elle obligeait jusqu'à taxi 4 il a pas
le droit de conduire
exactement je conduis dans les films en
fait voilà on a les autorisations
spéciales pour conduire sur les films et
tabassé les flics aussi on endroit là
c'est bien tu te régales là c'est bien
c'est qu'à la fin tu touches une
enveloppe mais sinon tu passes dans
lequel voire opposées voire 48 heures